hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today mentioning
another question from our YouTube
audience I love you guys this is from
Mark who wrote insane hi Evan great
video if you don't mind me asking what
books or ebooks would you recommend that
I may read so I can better learn about
business processes I've never been or
had any business education whatsoever in
the books that I've read for example
Rich Dad Poor Dad talks about building
your character as a business owner but
doesn't delve into how to operate a
business and I would like to learn more
about that thanks always for your advice
mark so a great question mark my
favorite book of all time at least so
far is the 4-hour workweek by Timothy
Ferriss and a lot of that is about
building processes to eliminate the crap
in your life and you may use it to work
a 4-hour workweek or continue to work
your regular workweek if you really love
what you're doing which I hope you guys
are doing but it gives you the mindset
to be able to remove the crap from your
life and focus on where you add the most
value and so some of the things to think
about are one to eliminate the things
that are not adding value and are not
your your highest use of time so look at
the things that you do every day in your
business and a lot of that can probably
eliminate like you don't have to do it
at all a quick example is I run a series
of mastermind groups here in Toronto
where entrepreneurs get together once a
month we talk about our business
problems and part of what I did as a
service was take minutes on what
everybody said and one month I got too
busy and didn't take the minutes and
send it out and the minutes took a lot
of time to write down and format and
send everybody and that one month when I
stop dickin the notes because I got too
busy nobody noticed I didn't send out
the notes and I thought this was this
huge value I'd service it was a great
idea and it turns out nobody cared about
it and so guess what I stopped doing it
I eliminated it and so there's a lot of
things that you're probably doing that
you can just eliminate straight out the
next thing is to automate and you look
at the the things that you're doing
regularly and see is there a way that
you can have software or some other
technology do this for you on an autumn
basis anything that I'm doing on a
repeated basis I always try to look for
a tool to help me do it
faster better if you look at any kind of
software tool you know it makes fewer
mistakes it doesn't go on vacation
doesn't call in sick it doesn't give you
problems and so much better to automate
wherever you can and then the next one
is a delegate so the things that still
have to get done that you can automate
but shouldn't shouldn't be you doing it
you delegate you find somebody who can
do it for you either overseas remotely
or locally here as well and that helps
set up the system so that you can focus
on what highest value could bring your
company and when I go to work every day
I ask myself along the way what's the
most value that I can bring to my
business today and I look at the tasks
that I have laid out in front of me and
I'll consistently challenge them like
should I be doing this should I be doing
this at all and if if I should should it
be me doing this I understand my company
has to do this but it should it be me
who's doing instead of somebody on my
team or some way to automate it and so
it's a personal challenge that I ask
myself every day that may be helpful for
you so that that's the mindset that
comes from the 4-hour workweek the
e-myth is another great book that you
can check out and I have a list of my
favorite books off my blog it's over
chemical comm slash blog and there's a
list of my top 10 favorite books or if
you're on my newsletter you get that
list as well and both of those are on
there so the email talks a lot about the
systems and structure you need to set up
to create your business there's a lot of
worksheets that I've created if you go
to the website slash worksheets you'll
be to find all the worksheets that I
have on there that mail for most may
also help you a lot of those are general
so that the worksheets the 4-hour work
week the e-myth are very it's general
advice general business systems which is
extremely helpful you haven't done
anything before it'll change how you
think and make you much better business
owner from there you might want to also
look at whatever industry you're in I
didn't see what kind of business you're
running but also follow some of the
blogs and experts who cover your
industry so for example I'm in online
marketing and so I research and I follow
a lot of the bloggers who talk about
online mark
and I look at some of the things that
they write about and often they'll post
about their workflow and things they do
to be more productive some of the tools
that they use and very very industry
specific so what may be really helpful
for them may not be helpful for
everybody else but as somebody in that
industry it's really useful so I look at
different companies who are blogging in
your space
and also different experts who are
consultants or people who are hired guns
who blog in that space as well and
follow them and you'll learn specific
skills and processes that they may use
that you may not find in a book like the
4-hour workweek or my worksheets or the
email so those are my two suggestions
one look at those general resources
because that will change how you think
as a business owner and that will easily
apply over to any any kind of business
and that's why those books are really
successful and then I try to follow
experts who are in your industry who
might give you other specific ideas that
can help you even further automate and
and make your systems a lot better so
hopefully that helps congratulations on
taking the time to invest in yourself
and think of ways to become a better
entrepreneur it's awesome for those of
you who are watching the video please
give it a thumbs up below if you liked
it that always makes my day to see the
thumbs ups come in and that makes Mona
do more of these videos and if you have
a comment about this video or a question
or a struggle that you're facing that
hopefully can help you with feel free to
leave in the comment section below I
always read those and try to respond as
soon as I can so thank you and I'll see
you in the next episode
you